somebody get him a therapy llama the GOP
primaries barely gotten started and the
liberal media is already freaking out
over every candidate that declares Ron
DeSantis is the latest Public Enemy
Number One after kicking off his first
rally in Iowa the Florida governor
taking it to Joe Biden and his other
Republican Rivals listen
we must restore sanity to our nation we
in the State of Florida held the line
when Freedom hung in the balance
leadership is not about entertainment
it's not about building a brand it's not
about virtue signaling it is about
results if we get distracted if we allow
the election to become about other
things other than Biden's failures if
he's able to hibernate in his basement
for the whole campaign and not have to
answer tough questions well then we may
be in danger of seeing a Democrat sweep
in 2024. now do you remember when the
media compared Donald Trump to Hitler
yeah well somehow Ron DeSantis is worse
presidential candidate and toy-sized
Mussolini Ron DeSantis unveils his
authoritarian Manifesto there is a model
for what this little dictator in the
making wants to do just look at China
Cuba North Korea Afghanistan or Iran his
candidacy is based on grievance politics
divisiveness and extreme policies Trump
and DeSantis are both anti-democratic
candidates they seek to be leaders of
autocratic movements
and if you think that's bad the views
co-host Sunny hoston says hold my beer
and his literally claiming Republican
women can't think for themselves
I think that women white women in
particular want to protect this
patriarchy here because it's to their
benefit they want to make sure that
their husbands do well they want to make
sure that their sons do well they want
to make sure that their children do well
and they want to make sure that they do
well most of the women and some of these
studies are married white women and they
do fall in line with what their husbands
are doing
so first of all judge thank you for
protecting the patriarchy yes behalf of
all men we really appreciate it you know
what's stunning I love it when a woman
says she knows how other women think
okay and I hate it when they actually do
a divide like that but you know Sunny
Hosten thinks that we're all protecting
white men and the white patriarchy and
that we can't think for ourselves I
wonder why it is that she is capable of
thinking for herself but I'm not going
to go there the amazing thing is you
have to wonder well then how did Barack
Obama get elected twice so I guess those
white women just when they see a black
person who's qualified I mean they
clearly elected Barack Obama it didn't
happen without white women so right
there is the failure of her whole Theory
but the thing about the left is they are
so hate-filled I mean DeSantis is a
Mussolini they talk about him like he's
like China Cuba North Korea
government-centered media is what Joy
Reid says are you kidding government
censored media is when the FBI meets
with Twitter and says don't you dare put
anything in there about that Russian
disinformation that Hunter Biden laptop
I mean that they are so dug in on hating
when they created the hate when it all
started with Hillary Clinton and the
basket of deplorables and then it goes
to the disgusting maggot I mean maggot
anymore as a negative connotation thanks
to Joe Biden and his blood red
background and the people with the guns
I mean they are just they they after a
while you don't listen to them and by
the way they're not using Hitler anymore
it's it's not Mussolini okay I guess
that's an Italian shot as a Democrat do
you think Ron DeSantis is more or less
dangerous than Donald Trump
I don't think of him and I I don't think
of it in that frame I agree with you
judge I I was a little concerned by the
language that uh that Sonny used around
that my wife is white and I'm black I
hope she roots for me I hope she's at
home
I'd say a couple things about uh Rhonda
about Mr DeSantis
um he has not presented well I don't
think in the first two weeks I I viewed
him as a Democrat some some ways maybe
how some Republicans thought about
Barack Obama in a way they may not have
been for him but there was something
interesting about and there was
something refreshing about the candidacy
and he he presented I thought well I
think a lot of Democrats I'm one of them
thought the Santas would present better
at the start he's come out and and at
the very beginning said he wants to to
do away with the left or he's gonna he's
gonna really get to get the left in
check that's half the country he's come
out and said he's going to arrest
teachers who teach certain books or who
have certain books in their class and I
have to understand you say I don't want
certain books but arresting teachers I
think is nuts and exacting revenge on
companies who you have a different
political view with you may be running
in the wrong country there's no nothing
wrong with saying I have a set of ideas
and I want the country to embrace my
ideas but be serious about it and I'm
hoping that's where where he finds
himself at some point because if he is
the nominee I think both parties have to
have strong nominees for the country to
have serious a serious choice and be
able to make a serious choice and thus
far I've been a little disappointed I
wouldn't go I wouldn't call him toy size
mussoline all that kind of stuff but I
have been disappointed in how he's
presented so far what happens if Joe
Biden arrests Donald Trump said okay uh
you and I have had this conversation I
think if if there's Not facts of course
not okay of course not
so Harold doesn't think DeSantis is
fresh enough Dana big enough and serious
enough I mean refreshing no no no no no
no no no no no I'm not talking at all
about about size I'm talking about the
series well but so you're at the herald
is a Democrat and he's probably not
going to vote for Ron DeSantis anyway so
but that's not the contest right now the
contest is amongst Republican primary
voters so and they'll decide if Ron
DeSantis is fresh enough for them or
what they want to do I mean right now
Donald Trump has such a commanding lead
over all of them that this is just
really getting started the The Campaign
kickoff for Ron DeSantis was yesterday
and so I do think that with like Sunny
housing Under The View
all of them actually that Montage we
showed they're absurdity strengthens the
Republicans at this point because
Republicans like oh yeah you've been
saying that about us and I think ever
since I got into politics since 1995
Democrats as I recall Democrats have
been saying this about Republican women
they just never change it's not talk
about not fresh like they got they got
nothing else and so they don't want to
defend their policies so what they try
to do is to make the other team more
toxic and just hope that nobody will
look at their policies and that they'll
vote based on that and they had some
success with that in 2022 but the
Republicans now have an opportunity to
continue on but I would also say to all
of them
our poll shows and all the I think all
the polls inflation and immigration
these are the two top issues for
Republican voters and you still have not
heard a lot about that on the trail so
far no you've heard a lot about Disney
and things like that but Greg do you
also think it's strange that on MSNBC
they'll call a Republican primary
candidate Mussolini but on Fox if you
have Marianne Williamson or you have RFK
Jr we actually invite them all in the
shows and ask them legitimate questions
yeah I think you know we might we have
our own kind of way of demonizing uh but
we don't do it the way they will say do
it Tastefully Tastefully I think we're
very we're very um a low-key in
demonizing people we'll call you we'll
say you smack of socialists but we won't
call you Hitler but we go like you know
but it is nice I do think it's
refreshing that they've moved on from
Hitler they probably had a morning
meeting they probably had like Pol Pot
no not enough people know who Pol Pot is
Mal well he's kind of short so maybe
Mussolini was tall and that's why they
said pint-sized Mussolini the point is
people have to wonder where does Sunny
Haas and get her opinions like you said
it's obviously from her husband uh she
has to tell her what to say in the view
because without it she's got nothing up
there she's not very bright so but the
problem with her is that she went full
racist she injected skin color into a
fairly generic Behavior seen in all
spouses regardless of of skin color
people bear it marry they listen to each
other they have something in common with
them they share their political views
um she just didn't want to upset her
husband by saying she she her husband
makes her do everything and then she'd
have to accuse him of being a racist
because if he told her that this is what
white women do then he's a racist
see I follow yes very much so I think
Republicans have to ask themselves who
do the Dems want to run against and why
aren't they saying so
because I think that's going to be the
hardest question for the Republicans
right now you might know that the guy
you love has the primary in the bag
because there's no primary whatever but
why aren't people going after the other
guy as much I don't know that this is
the things I'm thinking about while I'm
watching this knowing that every single
Republican is going to have a rough ride
because that that road is going to be
paved with demonization Hitler
comparisons Mussolini comparisons the
coming apocalypse death chaos
destruction doesn't matter who it is so
while Donald Trump and I've said this
before may be a two-hour drive to an
hour at the beach
it's going to be like that with all of
them did Santa's it might be 90-minute
drive to a half an hour at the beach
either way it's going to be no day at
the beach for anybody so Republicans
need to match it and be as as I guess as
fiery and as aggressive as they are
because they're gonna they're coming for
the next right and just demonize
Tastefully demonized taste yes exactly
not clumsy like they do over there I
wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now